[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera
cargo desde el parlamento europeo en
bruselas es un placer saludarles en el
programa de hoy el primero del año
analizamos las relaciones entre la unión
europea y américa latina que le espera
la región en este 2022 antes de pasar al
debate repasamos brevemente la situación
entre la unión europea y américa latina
la unión europea sigue tratando de
desplegar su política exterior común por
todo el mundo y américa latina' forma
parte importante de esa agenda aunque
las relaciones exteriores del bloque se
han centrado sobre todo en asia para
contrarrestar la influencia china y en
áfrica por el flujo migratorio américa
latina' se ha vuelto un continente
importante debido a la progresiva
influencia que ejerce en el gigante
asiático y rusia en la región la
comisión europea ha propuesto
recientemente la creación del portal
global un proyecto de inversiones
mundial que haga frente a lo conocido
como ruta de la ciudad china la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
von der leyen ya ha dejado claro que
quiere que américa latina' forme parte
de este proyecto para prestarle apoyo en
educación en la lucha contra la crisis
climática
ya la unión europea ha dado otros pasos
en materia de ayuda a la región contra
la pandemia donando más de 50 millones
de dosis de vacunas contra el cubit sin
embargo también se ha criticado que no
haya prestado más atención a la región
latinoamericana en los últimos años
tampoco se ha ratificado el esperado
acuerdo comercial con los países de
mercosur ahora bloqueado después de más
de 20 años de negociaciones el
parlamento europeo rechazó la aprobación
del pacto en su forma actual sobre todo
por la política medioambiental del
presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro y
que de momento no hay fecha para que
entre en vigor
y para poner un poco de contexto y
abordar cómo se encaran estas relaciones
entre la unión europea y américa latina
en el debate de europa hoy contamos con
el eurodiputado del grupo
socialdemócrata iván garcía del blanco
bienvenido iván y con el eurodiputado
del partido popular europeo
leopoldo lopez jil bienvenido leopoldo 6
gracias muchas gracias a los dos por
estar aquí en europa hoy me gustaría
empezar primero de todo con iván este
2022 américa latina enfrenta importantes
citas electorales tenemos las
presidenciales en colombia en brasil
este último precisamente podría
repetirse un escenario muy parecido lo
que ha ocurrido en chile con dos
candidatos totalmente opuestos el
espectro ideológico está américa latina'
más polarizada que nunca bueno yo creo
que el mundo está muy polarizado europa
también lo está américa latina que
probablemente tenía unas circunstancias
también muy especiales que tiene que ver
pues con que son países muy jóvenes con
democracias jóvenes con un pasado además
sobre todo durante los 80 muy muy
difícil pues ya lo era y evidentemente
se se polariza un poco más pues ocurre
lo que está pasando pero yo creo que la
buena noticia en realidad es que las
democracias más allá de algún mal
ejemplo
pero las democracias están aguantando y
los sistemas democráticos están
aguantando yo creo que hay que poner el
foco en aquellos países que están
corriendo riesgo hay algunos sobre todo
en la zona de centroamérica ya con
dificultades y que podría derivar en
algo que no nos gusta pero en general
las democracias están aguantando se
están viendo un traspaso de poderes con
toda normalidad y bueno al final pues
esos países será lo que quieran sus
ciudadanos y creo que es evidente
también que se está dando un giro
político en el continente de la mayoría
de derechas prácticamente en toda la
región pues estos países están girando
no hacia un planteamiento pues de
izquierda más de izquierda populista
yo creo que también la
el rasgo principal que tienen muchos de
estos partidos y la polarización de la
política de la política latinoamericana
pero en fin yo creo que también dejar un
tiempo a todos estos gobiernos ya todas
estas democracias para que se vayan
asentando y vayan pasando los efectos
además de lakovic 19 que haya sido
durísimo lo ha sido en europa y allí lo
ha sido todavía muchísimo más pero como
digo las democracias están aguantando
las perspectivas económicas también
están siendo muy buenas frente a quien
anticipaba que iba a sufrir mucho más
latinoamérica de lo que iba a sufrir el
resto del mundo parece que los datos nos
dicen que las cosas van bastante mejor
de lo de lo previsto en fin yo creo que
otra vez el papel de europa es ayudar
estar al lado y no digerir pero pero
echar una mano en aquello que se nos
pueda necesitar y desde luego desde la
perspectiva pues española pues muchísimo
más es evidente de nuestros nuestros
lazos nuestros intereses y un futuro
también que tiene que ser compartido
preocupa mucho la situación en venezuela
un país que usted conoce muy bien por
primera vez desde 2006 se envía una
misión electoral a las elecciones pero
que el partido popular europeo no apoyo
cuál debería ser la estrategia con
venezuela bueno tendríamos que aclarar
primero por qué no apoyó el partido
popular el envío de una misión no fue
exactamente
una decisión del partido popular por la
misión en sí sino porque en la
metodología que se utilizó por el
servicio exterior es decir el señor
josep borrel fue enviar primero una
misión exploratoria para ver si había
condiciones que justificaron una misión
de observación las conclusiones de esa
misión exploratoria fue que no habían y
no iban a haber en condiciones para
observar o porque no iban a hacer unas
elecciones
verificables transparentes etcétera
etcétera y
después de haber recibido pues una
condición negativa por parte de sus
expertos se tomó la decisión de enviarlo
sin haber comunicado al parlamento el
proceso del por qué se tomaba esa
decisión por lo tanto nosotros estuvimos
en desacuerdo
es un procedimiento absolutamente
irregular sí sí tú manda una misión
exploratoria te dice que no y tú decides
mandar las tienes que aclarar el porqué
cuál es el resultado que obviamente
todavía no tenemos el informe final pero
las conclusiones y las sabe muy bien el
público que no habían las condiciones
para llamarlas transparentes
democráticas verificables etcétera el
ejemplo fue como le robaron las
elecciones en uno de los estados que es
el estado barinas al darle al ganador y
luego después de un proceso muy tortuoso
la semana pasada se celebraron de nuevo
unas elecciones a la cual no se asistió
afortunadamente para observar
y graciano de nuevo la oposición
con un margen pues bastante importante
un 56 por ciento contra un 46 44 por
ciento
del gobierno y yo creo que se
justificaba bien el haber aceptado lo
que decía la misión de exploración que
no iba a haber condiciones verificables
cuál es la condición ahora nosotros
tenemos que seguir apoyando
exigiendo desde el punto de vista e
internacional y particularmente europeo
que se continúen las negociaciones en la
mesa de mexico y que se logre lo que
todos estamos pidiendo que es el
calendario que lleve a unas elecciones
verificables transparentes
presidenciales no lo que fueron las
anteriores que esto que celebraron pues
recientemente en diciembre y la semana
pasada que son regionales solamente lo
que hay que cambiar es un régimen que ha
llevado a venezuela durante 20 años del
socialismo del siglo 21 de un país
próspero a un país que está hoy a nivel
de haití
con 6 millones de sus habitantes fuera
de venezuela que han tenido que emigrar
porque no tienen condiciones ni de
seguridad de alimentación ni de sanidad
y por lo tanto buscan donde
desempeñar el resto de su vida fuera de
sus sitios de nacimiento es muy triste
pero creo que es la función de europa
tiene que decir ser firme seguir con el
proceso de sanciones a quienes han
cometido las barbaridades de corrupción
que han cometido en estos 20 años lo son
los actuales sátrapas que están en el
régimen como gobernante y apoyar a la
población en general para que logren el
retorno a la democracia y tanto acudiste
a venezuela en esta misión electoral con
fue tu experiencia que cuál crees que
debe ser la solución la estrategia en
venezuela bueno antes decía que los
tiempos estaban también de latinoamérica
yo creo que también están cambiando en
venezuela es evidente que el
estado de opinión y el humor del país
también está cambiando es evidente
también que se está reduciendo el apoyo
que podía tener eventualmente
el régimen de maduro y que es evidente
también que después de 20 años de una
estrategia de confrontación de
aislamiento no hemos llegado a ningún
punto que pueda ayudar a esa transición
tengo que decir que la misión de
observación fue pedida de manera
mayoritaria por parte de la oposición
que escogió
afrontar estas elecciones como una forma
también de comenzar a reconstruir una
vía de salida democrática a las
elecciones y creo que además que la
misión ha sido muy honesta en el
planteamiento de qué es lo que ha
ocurrido en estas elecciones de
venezuela
ánimo mucho a
leer las conclusiones de la misión de
observación que no avaló estas
elecciones pero que de alguna manera así
que produjo que las condiciones de
partida que las condiciones de
competición entre el régimen y la
oposición fueran más equilibradas de lo
que han sido nunca la historia yo
coincido con que ahora lo que hay es que
facilitar que haya unas elecciones
presidenciales en igualdad de
condiciones en la medida de nuestras
posibilidades y creo que el papel de
europa tiene que ser precisamente ese
tratar con con mano izquierda de buscar
puntos de encuentro de apoyar los
esfuerzos que está haciendo la oposición
junto con que también los hay algunas
variantes del propio régimen de maduro
más aperturista y que pueda facilitar
esa vía y esa salida democrática y de
alguna forma a ver si en muy poco tiempo
tenemos eso unas elecciones que
faciliten esa solución porque como digo
la estrategia de confrontación no nos ha
llevado a ninguna parte hasta este
momento y tampoco creo que la posición
de europa no sólo con venezuela sino en
toda la región y si se me apura en todo
el mundo no pueda
hacer un
seguimiento unilateral por parte de la
política de la administración
norteamericana creo que tenemos que ser
un agente autónomo que de alguna manera
también aproveche el prestigio
internacional que tiene acumulado para
poder ser útil en la salida desde este
tipo de situaciones como la que está
teniendo venezuela desde todo el respeto
a la posición que ha mantenido el
partido popular que yo creo que ha sido
equivocada pero entiendo también que
estamos como digo viviendo cambios y no
todo el mundo tiene la capacidad ni las
condiciones a veces de poder adaptarse
al mismo al mismo ritmo pero yo creo que
lo importante es que acabemos en el
mismo lugar todos los grupos políticos
con representación en esta cámara es
evidente por ejemplo lo que ha ocurrido
con el grupo liberal que yo aplaudo creo
que lo que nos queda y sería imposible
buscar una solución es que el partido
popular también esté en ese consenso
buscando esta solución democrática nos
queda muy poco tiempo por lo tanto me
gustaría que fueran un breve es creemos
que europa puede estar dejando de lado a
américa latina' brevemente leopoldo creo
que es lamentablemente si hacemos un
examen de los últimos años
américa latina no ha estado en las
prioridades de europa por mucho tiempo y
sí creo que se ha preocupado un poco más
últimamente y muy particularmente porque
españa ha tomado un intento de liderazgo
para llevar a la agenda del parlamento
de europa en general
para américa latina y ahora con la
apertura pues con el portal global hay
una gran oportunidad para que europa
realmente pueda transformar un poco con
los valores que tiene y la razón de
existir de la unión europea los valores
democráticos en el respeto a los
derechos humanos cosas que yo estoy en
desacuerdo que a veces estos
entendimientos no no no no nos han
llevado a nada y el ejemplo de 60 años
en cuba tratando de entender los
diferenciando unos de la política
americana no creo que ha ayudado mucho a
los cubanos yo creo que en la
confrontación no es esto lo que estoy
sugiriendo que tenemos que seguir la
política americana sino tener nosotros
nuestra propia
pero que la política tiene que ser
contundente con respecto a los derechos
humanos y sobre todo a los valores
democráticos muchas gracias a vamos ha
sido un debate breve pero intenso muy
interesante muchísimas gracias a los dos
y ya ustedes les esperamos en el próximo
programa de europa hoy muchas gracias
por ver france24 en español
[Música]